okay ready guys
audition them there's a lot of pressure
here
my name is nick borrelli and i'm
traveling the country to sit down with
some of the biggest latinx artists in
places that are meaning to them and help
tell their stories we'll talk about
their journeys and careers and explore
issues of identity culture
discrimination and representation this
is scene
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm back in la driving through bell
gardens on my way to bell gardens
intermediate to meet mr olmos he
actually played a huge role in the
movies that affected me through my
adolescence and childhood standard
deliver me familia and selena were all
movies that made me feel proud to be
latino mr almost chose belle gardens
intermediate as a place for us to meet
because it's one of the schools that his
program ycp youth cinema project is
actually heavily involved in and
integrating film studies into public
school curriculum so excited to talk to
the kids and mr almost
mr almost
thank you for your time you're welcome
man do you mind if uh we take these off
i got my booster and all my other shots
yeah same so of all the places in la
this is the one you picked why is this
place special to you this school
district the montebello unified school
district has been one of the most
prolific school districts we've had for
this program i wish we had this uh when
i was growing up because for me when i
moved to this country not speaking
english i became really introverted i
was a kid at the back of the class who
didn't say much he was shot open up my
mouth so i think talking and writing and
those things are can be a challenge for
someone whose english is a second
language we internalize it it questions
our self-worth it plays into so many
different layers all of our students
end up with a much stronger sense of
self-worth when they're done with this
program we start in the fourth grade we
tried it at a younger age but they
weren't quite ready yet
first grade everybody loves school
second grade you're starting to learn
stuff whether you speak the language you
don't you're still involved
third grade becomes the grade where they
start to read and write and so if you
speak another language first and you're
not quite up to speed so that wasn't the
place where we should be at that moment
where we needed to catch them is in the
fourth grade when they had now lost
their sense of balance
and they were like feeling less than who
they are and we bring them into this
program and they excel
i can honestly tell you this what we've
been able to understand will make you
cry
it brings a sense of emotion because
you're standing there looking at kids
if you saw them just before they got
into the program and you see it during
the program you would sit there and go
my god these kids are are so
communicative
of course you're making a movie right
you have to you have no choice
one's a director one's a producer one's
the writer one's the you know camera
person and and basically you find
yourself inside of this
making a movie
and they all have their stories we're
not teaching them out of a book they're
teaching us out of their stories let's
go in the classroom
[Music]
all right quite on set
all right so we're wrapping up our
auditions how does everybody feel
you're good okay so
hi mr olmos how are you hey how are you
guys
[Music]
it's good to see you good to see you
we're working on our auditions for our
films this year yeah if their names
crossed off they've already auditioned
how did they do you guys
i'm
answered
proud of you guys are they all in the
program these are oic peeps this is my
good friend nick he's actually doing
an interview on me
for the academy motion picture arts and
sciences and that you're
mr your assistant director here i'm the
producer producer
i'm the director
congratulations man and you're i'm
auditioning oh right now for the role of
andres well you want to do it
uh no pressure there's a lot of pressure
here
okay ready guys
audition them
this is a robbery get down
jackson hurry up set up the
communication trey hurry up and set up
the dribbling equipment can you see
we're doing just that besides what are
you doing just sitting there hey don't
talk back to me
i'm your leader respect me
how did you feel about that one
you know i liked it
[Music]
excellent
and you're auditioning right now yes
let me hear it
good morning jamie father miller you
seem really excited for class today wait
is there a free period today no silly
today professor ron is going to announce
the final project of the semester oh you
have to remind me it's not that bad i've
already organized my full schedule to
fit in with the assignment how can you
be so organized
i loved it you did really good i just
feel like you had a bit more movement
when you're like oh you had to remind me
that's good i think maybe this was good
have you directed before no it's your
first time how do you like it i really
like it because i feel like i can make
the actors like
have a better performance like when they
come in they're good but i kind of want
to give them like adjustments on how
they could be way better and on top of
it and really good
i just want to thank all of you very
much for everything you guys are doing
you guys are truly the future and
whether you become filmmakers or you
don't become filmmakers that's not the
issue the issue is that you've gotten
the opportunity to understand yourselves
your stories
and you learn self-esteem self-respect
and self-worth congratulations all of
you i'm very proud of you
all right give yourselves a round of
applause
we'd love to continue the conversation
let's sit down perfect
wow those kids being able to recite
lines in front of cameras that was
pretty amazing
how does it feel to to see the
generation start
that young into the craft that you've uh
you've mastered all these decades this
is a dream
you don't quite get it
until you really experience the
differences and these kids have become
whole
they're able to look at you and to talk
with you
they have confidence self-esteem
self-respect and they've only been doing
it for like six months
i always like to start interviews kind
of like the intro sequence of a movie
like when that pan shot comes into your
childhood home what are we seeing what
are we hearing what are we smelling wow
i come from the ellis island of the west
coast that's what it's called so my my
background came from
being just a kid in east l.a playing in
in uh there was no grass or anything it
was just dirt lots and it was it was
beautiful there was a lot of love but it
was not
any kind of fluent
living whatsoever how did growing up in
east l.a shape you well it gave me a
sense of balance of who i was because uh
we were
you know multitude of cultures
so we had indigenous people living right
to my right hand as i come on my front
door there was a house with apache
indians to the left there was a family
of the martinez they were
mexican-american right across the street
with japanese family they all had kids
and all of us played together and what
happened by coming from there i was
exposed to the clarity
of culture
and i didn't know
anything about any kind of
cultural differences discrimination or
any kind of prejudices at all
so we were exposed to
religions we're exposed to cultures and
i thought that that's how the whole
world was
until i left i crossed the l.a river
over the first street bridge and i saw
that
there was
still africans but they were in one
corner indigenous people were not even
you could find them and then the asian
community was stuck in another corner
the latino community was in pocoymon in
the valley
and the caucasian community was on the
west side and it was quite
interesting your first level was
actually baseball you were a catcher you
caught sandy koufax we shared something
my knees still hurt from when i used the
cats and uh eddie roebuck was the guy
that i really worked with the most
during that period of time sandy pitched
too but we were playing the california
sun league and i played every day seven
days a week i learned uh the whole
understanding of you had to spend ten
thousand hours to master you would just
be all that you could be and didn't make
you better than anybody else right it
just made you whole
that that discipline you know to do the
things you love to do when you don't
feel like doing them
came to light and i was four or five
years old when i stumbled onto this and
so by the time i was 12 11 12
i was playing really strongly and i was
catching and like you you know my niece
oh boy we used to do double headers and
sometimes triple headers so i was
playing 21 innings a day it was single a
ball getting ready to go into double a
and triple a and getting picked up by
the majors that's part of the dodger
system right yes yeah that was one of
them so you're
on your way to become a professional
baseball player right you're you're in
the dodger system you're 13 you get your
discipline from baseball then you're
like at some point you're like i want to
be in a rock band what was that moment
like and were you remember how did your
parents feel about that moment destroyed
my father
i'll never forget it uh he didn't quite
get it but i uh how could i he have
gotten it everybody in the world told
him that you know this he's a really
natural
natural
naturally just
yes
he's so hard to work make you a natural
man
there was nothing natural about me
playing baseball there was nothing
natural about me being a rock and roll
singer there was nothing natural about
me being an actor
what drew you to rock and roll what was
it about rock and roll that the cop it
was the rhythm
the intense rhythms that and and the
feeling that you got listening to it my
father who was a very good dancer and my
mother was too but he was for me a great
great
uh asset of understanding because he was
a he could move
and so we would clean the house and
stuff he'd put on press prado or he'd
put on tito puente he put on all the
great latin music you know that there
was and while he was cleaning we were
cleaning and stuff he would move and so
we would see him moving and we'd start
to win
dying of laughter because when you're a
little kid and
you're doing all these things you never
did before but you're moving to the
music so he got me into music and that's
what happens when you get exposed to
certain things it changes your
perspective on life so in 1960 i was
playing baseball every day seven days a
week but then i realized that [ __ ] you
know what
i want to sing and dance
i love baseball but
i really love
singing and dancing
and moving
and so
i went into that the same way i played
baseball i hung up my cleats 14 years
old i hung up my cleats
and my father lost it
and it was sad because he really got
hurt by it i didn't know how much
because i was still stuck on my own
world i'm gonna sing her down you know
what the heck's wrong with you but then
he realized that i started doing the
music like i had done baseball pretty
soon i was performing
couldn't sing very well but man could i
perform i could move and dance using my
latin and my african roots i would
perform seven days a week so we were
constantly working
and then one day um i went to audition
for a play they asked for two latino
actors to go up to the the main stages
of
of los angeles which is the mark taper
and wow they they sent me as one of the
guys so i went i didn't get the part but
as i was walking out i heard a hey you
and i turned around and i'm
miscellaneous girl young girl and she
goes yeah you uh you yeah yeah i'm
talking to you do you want to try out
for a play that we're doing i said uh
what play she goes do you or don't you i
go yes i do yes i do
i could see that she was like
questioning why she even stopped me and
so she can i go yes yes yes i would
thank you she goes okay be here on
monday at the three o'clock so i left
came back on monday at three o'clock
there was hundreds of guys there
and there was this play called zootsu so
i got to do that that was a combination
abusing theater
movement
singing all of the things that i've been
doing
day in and day out for years because
i've been doing theater since 1964. i
got in my first acting class in east l.a
community college can you speak a little
bit about what went into that character
what were all the elements that came
into you crafting pachuco everything
that i had been working towards and
understanding through my life were
funneled into this i could use it in
this performance
this character became capable of using
it all i mean it was amazing what
happened with that character el pachuco
to this day
is still profoundly one of the most
beloved characters to arise on the
american stage in the history of
american theater not not me saying that
that was the american theater wing said
it
and i mean it was the character granted
i was capable of handling the
responsibility which was
thank the lord i was ready because we
really needed it the year was 1978 and
there had never been a play dealing with
the latino culture other than west side
story but
studying the puerto rican and west side
story was like studying the polynesian
in south pacific
it wasn't meant to study the culture it
was meant to use the culture to tell a
story which was fine this was the first
time the culture had ever spoken
this was a culture that spoke
and then what it said was monumental
that plane changed the perspectives and
the understandings of the latino culture
in this country and opened it up how did
it feel for a group of kids in east l.a
not only to put on for the city but then
go to broadway and send ripples
throughout the world i mean i read that
people were coming in from like london
theater and moscow theater and all these
different places just to see what you
guys were doing yeah they did and they
came when we were here in l.a and the
one shot was heard around the world
that's how strong
the the piece was
i have to give it to luis and to gordon
davidson those two giants of the
american theater
were the people who really created this
and allowed it to be born
i read that you did 13 years of theater
without getting a paycheck is that true
yeah all right can you speak on that
because i feel like people hear that and
they're like you like you have to really
love something to do it for 13 years for
nothing i play baseball for
nothing i mean you're in this rock band
you're not getting paid you're doing
theater you're not getting paid like i'm
you probably have other jobs that are
paying the bills while you're
furniture you're delivering furniture
yeah yeah i mean that's how i supported
myself for a long time too i had a a van
from playing in rock and roll music you
know between the situations of working
on stage i would deliver like two
o'clock in the morning three o'clock in
the morning i'd be delivering furniture
from auctions wow so you're performing
and then at two o'clock you're going to
deliver furniture yeah
from two to seven that's dedication
i feel like one of the most empowering
things of your career is that you found
a way to make all the characters you
played your own how are you able to
accomplish that since el pachuco i've
had creative control of my characters
and no one argues no one says you know
eddie no no no no no no no i could have
never worked with alfred hitchcock he
didn't need anybody else to add to his
movies okay i get it that's perfect go
for it just don't call me because i
might think of something that might
enhance your story
and that's all i do i mean there's some
times when i i never change a dot a
period nothing
you know i'd do exactly what's on the
page because it's perfectly done
and then sometimes i'll augment it and
move it to another level and they're
very grateful
take me to a stand and deliver
tell me a little bit about how that came
to be made because i i heard that it
took five years for that to happen yeah
you guys filmed it independently is that
correct yes yes we did anyone who sees
it is such a powerful story but when you
pitched it to hollywood what were they
telling you in terms of why they
couldn't finance it well basically the
the one line that they'd really just
like
it was like a ton of bricks so we would
go like the nbc or cps something and nbc
said you know the day that you want to
do this story which is a wonderful story
don't get me wrong and uh they say you
know they'll play terminator on the same
night that we're playing stand and
deliver what do you think people are
gonna watch
and i said
stand and deliver that's a better story
and they chuckled and they let us leave
the room no we got our money funding
from the public broadcasting pbs
and the american playhouse
which started the seed money it cost us
about a million too
to do the movie wow so we got 10 000
from this person 15 000 from this person
200 000 from this person
you know different people gave us to
make up for the 1.2 million that we
needed to make the movie we captured
lightning in a box
and i'm very grateful because that movie
has helped
so many people i saw it recently and it
definitely stands a test of time what do
you think it is about the movie that can
resonate from generation to generation i
think it's the story
the story itself the truth of the story
itself
is is powerful a hundred years from
today
that movie will be seen and understood
and and be appreciated all we want to do
was just document
the behavior of this man
and we did it and i was very fortunate i
was able to do it
edward james almost for stand and
deliver it did not have spanish surnames
and come from barrio schools you know
that
there's something going on here that
nobody is talking about
and you know what it is
i know well how to spell discrimination
i thought this was over a long time ago
are you doing this to my kids
my kids could teach you a thing or two
johnny
i'm gonna call security if you can't
control yourself escalante go for it
that movie you received the nomination
for uh best leading actor
you are the only us-born latino to be
nominated for best actor or best actress
in the history of the academy in the
history of the academy why do you think
it's
been such a struggle to get another u.s
born latino to that to that stage where
they could be nominated latino or latina
because it applies to both either way
it's just a story the roles are what
define it
and it's been very hard to get uh
uh
that
opportunity like for instance
argo a beautiful movie best movie of the
year when it came out
got all kinds of accolades for for ben
affleck and everything but it didn't win
him the academy award
had he used a latino
which is what the story was about yeah
it was about a mexican-american but
nobody ever knew it tony mendez was the
character that they portrayed but they
used his name a couple of times but it's
so thrown away that most people you
could ask him right did you know that
this was a mexican-american person
it was a mexican-american culture
no no you've been a strong advocate for
representation for a long time uh why is
that important for you to me trying to
understand your life
and in your culture
and and your heritage
and
the roots that make you the tree that
you are or the human being that you are
sharing it so that others can understand
it
makes everybody stronger
and that's why i'm a storyteller and
that's why i got into this and that's
why i stand here today telling stories
and trying desperately hard to
listen
listening is the key
i listen to you nick
you're very very educated in respects of
knowing who and what i am and i'm very
proud of the fact that i'm being
interviewed by someone who really
understands who
who i am and uh it makes a big
difference and i appreciate you doing
the work that you've done to understand
what you're doing here today if you
don't know how uh how
seen i feel at this moment like i feel
like it's been 25 years to get on the
seat just like you said that the 13
years of theater the normal paid or
whatever it's like it all comes
to this place right now yes it does
throughout your career
you've not only acted you've directed
you've written stuff you've produced why
is it important for you to wear multiple
hats out of a necessity to stay alive
in this industry
i had to learn
the full usage of storytelling whether
it be in songwriting filmmaking or
theater if we weren't creating it we
weren't going to be able to do because
nobody was creating it for us seeing
what you've seen experience with the
experience what will you tell a young
actor director writer latino latina
who's watching this
who who maybe hasn't seen as much of
themselves represented when they turn on
the streamers or go to the movies
but who wants to do it what advice would
you have for them the strongest advice i
can give any artist in any perspective
of
the disciplines is don't stop
don't let anything stop you
die doing it
you know just don't stop uh you know
success is not money it's not fame it's
not fortune success is having lived your
life
doing what you really wanted to do
and doing it to the best of your ability
that means you spend thousands of hours
doing it in this lifetime just don't
stop
don't let anything stop you
because the key is to do the things you
want to do when you don't feel like
doing them
so the moment you want to stop and say
this is too much i can't take the
rejection or you know no one really
cares about my music no one cares about
my movies nobody cares about me nobody
cares about anything ah
i don't care about me i don't care about
myself i'm stopping
that
never can you do
you must never stop
you've had iconic roles
you helped found la life use cinema
latino public broadcast we can go on and
on and on and on what's left to
accomplish for you when i pass and leave
this world i could have
done
way more work because i would have been
offered a lot of work more work i've
been offered than i've taken
people say why do you do that you
could've been a lot more famous and a
lot richer
i said yeah but in essence i wouldn't
have felt the way i feel right this
moment you know i have movies that i'd
like to make that i've been trying to
make for 35 years that i still have been
able to make
you know and i hope that i can make them
and if i don't i'm going to die trying
and that's all i can tell you
thank you for your time thank you for
for all the doors that you've opened and
knocked down for for generations to come
thank you for full circle moment we're
we're here in the classroom sand and
deliver was so impactful and now we're
actually in a classroom with kids and
impacting a whole new generation thank
you for for all that you do my honor my
privilege thank you for your kindness
your respect
[Music]
it's hard to even put what just happened
in words i feel all this like rush of
energy
uh coming through me i just feel
gratitude for mr almost sharing his time
and the moment where he just
acknowledged the research and just the
work you know being in this industry for
25 years you don't really have a lot of
moments like that like where you
actually feel like what i'm doing is
being seen by by this person that i look
up to and have admired my whole life so
i can't even know what the next episode
is going to be and how we're going to be
able to top this but we're going to find
a way to uh to bring this level of
energy to every episode that we do
[Music]
[Applause]